so much has happened over the course of
the pandemic that it's easy to forget
how a year and a half ago new york city
was the worst hot spot in america it was
on this exact date 18 months ago that a
healthcare worker who lived in manhattan
became the cities and the state's first
confirmed case of the coronavirus the
city and its surrounding suburbs over 20
million people had far more cases than
many countries had at the time and
certainly more than the rest of the
nation this is what the u.s looked like
on april the 15th of last year with new
york state outpacing the rest of the
country most of those cases in the city
of new york now look at how the
situation has evolved across the u.s
since then in this interactive map from
our friends at pbs newshour as cases of
the chronovirus have exploded among the
unvaccinated particularly in the south
but
turning back the clock in new york city
at the start of the pandemic
refrigeration trucks would be brought in
to serve as makeshift morgues a
charitable organization would build a
field hospital in central park among the
dog walkers and not far from where kids
would still play to handle its overflow
of patients from mount sinai hospital
across fifth avenue the military would
convert the city's massive convention
center into another field hospital the
navy would send its hospital ship to
dock in the hudson river and every night
at 7 pm this is what new york city would
sound like
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cheering
clapping and the banging of pots and
pans as new yorkers gathered at their
windows to thank healthcare workers it
was the sound of hope
all the while the mayor bill de blasio
and then governor andrew cuomo were
under fire for their initial response to
the crisis much of the time the two were
fighting about their coveted strategies
with each other over when to shut down
and what to shut down and who had the
authority to do so and how to
communicate it all to the public but
things in new york eventually got better
if not between the mayor and the
governor at least things got better
regarding the coronavirus central park
went from hosting a field hospital to
holding a homecoming concert new york's
vaccination drive was part of that and
yet with the delta variant and school
starting and colder weather just around
the corner there are questions about
whether it will be enough
joining us now to talk about all of this
is the mayor of new york city then and
now bill de blasio
mr mayor thanks so much for joining me
on the show tonight you've done a lot
recently to get new yorkers vaccinated
educators have to be vaccinated health
care workers city employees they have to
be vaccinated or tested weekly there are
new vaccine mandates for restaurants
other public venues i welcome all of
that i wish republican governors in the
south were doing what you're doing but i
wonder do you have more planned on the
vaccination front given the scale of the
challenge what else can you do to get
numbers up
well mary i have to tell you we've had a
vision of fighting back aggressively
with mandates with incentives as well
including uh the hundred dollar
incentive for anyone who comes in new to
get vaccinated
something uh president biden bought into
right away and encouraged folks to do
all over the country that's been really
helpful so
i keep saying we're climbing a ladder
of both incentives and mandates
to find more and more ways
to reach people and it's having a huge
impact the vaccination numbers are going
up markedly and many they're
particularly going up amongst black and
latino new yorkers
and we are literally at this point
willing to go to people's homes we will
send vaccinators to your homes
to be able to give you in-person
vaccination for your whole family and
each family member gets 100 incentive
who's eligible to be vaccinated i mean
this is a very
hands-on grassroots effort
it's making a huge impact and people are
really copying a lot of the things we're
doing here there's a powerful poll that
the hill just came out with almost a
thousand employers
making clear that about half of them
already are putting vaccine mandates of
different kinds in place when the
nation's largest city moves it helps
public and private sector move around
the country that was part of what we
hope to do and we're really seeing the
impact now
so what's next what more can be done to
get those numbers higher is it a matter
of paying people more giving more money
out
i think we're going to look at a range
of options including
of course the potential for additional
mandates we we have a sense i certainly
believe in sequencing right now the
focus is on bringing school back it's
just a couple of weeks away that's a
very strong mandate we're going to make
sure that works
but we're looking at a variety of other
options
but also the incentive front is really
important to note the hundred dollar
incentive has been particularly
effective we have a new incentive we've
just started with physicians
we finally got some federal support for
this to literally provide extra
financial support to physicians if they
systematically reach out to their
patients to talk about vaccination to
encourage it to demystify it to help
people make appointments we want to
reward individual physicians who
literally take a list of all their
patients and work all the way through it
because that's one of the most trusted
voices in anyone's life interesting and
but it hasn't been organized as such and
there hasn't been the kind of resource
incentive that would help we've now put
those pieces together 35 million program
here in the city that i think is going
to make a big difference
we can only hope uh mr mayor i also saw
that regarding restaurants in your city
you announced that patent patrons will
be allowed to dine as soon as they get
their first covered shot literally as
soon as they've got the shot you said
which is a nice sentiment but it makes
no scientific sense does it given you
don't get immunity from the virus
straight after the shot especially the
first shot it takes a couple of weeks
it makes strategic sense and this is why
our healthcare leaders have really
bought into this idea because it's an
incentive to get more people vaccinated
look maddie the whole idea was
vaccination you can talk about any other
tools any other pieces of the equation
but what we decided here having been the
epicenter as you powerfully laid out
earlier we decided there's one strategy
it's vaccination getting to the most
pervasive level of vaccination possible
now i'm happy to tell you 77
of adults in new york city right now
have gotten at least one dose and almost
everyone who gets the first dose comes
back for the second so the strategic
idea there was let's say to people
particularly young people who have been
more hesitant less engaging in the
vaccine you want to enjoy life in new
york city it's one of the things young
people flock here to do the restaurants
the bars the concerts you want all that
you have to be vaccinated but we're not
telling you you have to wait a month or
six weeks we're trying to get people to
just get started immediately even the
first dose infers some protection we
know that scientifically
but this is strategic well this is about
conducting the movement
it doesn't confirm protection
immediately though
it doesn't convert
but i think your point about incentives
right it confers protection but our
point is a strategic one if someone gets
vaccinated for the first time
they are on the pathway to getting
vaccinated totally and that and there's
plenty of other
safety measures on top of that let's be
clear including in our restaurants
but the key is get people vaccinated
you've got to get them started
agreed
mr may you've earned plaudits for your
leadership on covid on vaccinations this
year as you said you've led the way on
some of the mandate policies but looking
back on that awful period in new york's
history the start of the pandemic the
spring of 2020 your critics as you know
say you mishandled the situation you
didn't take the pandemic seriously
enough early enough i want to play a bit
of sound and get your reaction on the
other side have a listen
look we're also telling people to not
avoid restaurants not avoid
um you know the normal
uh things they would do this does not
transmit through food or drink so
people should go out and continue to
live life should go out to restaurants
in hindsight saying carry on with life
as normal on march the 11th that was the
day the w.h.o officially declared a
pandemic that was a mistake we can all
agree right now can't we
well based on what we know now of course
but that's not the point the point is we
the information we had the time at the
time we had evidence of a small number
of cases
we did not know until much later how
pervasive the disease already had become
even in february
and i was listening of course to my
health leadership and the goal was to
not say to people that we had reached a
point for shutting down our society but
trying to strike a balance trying to
address the cases we had
and get people to do the precautions
that our health team were important
thought were important at the time
unfortunately within a few days it
became clear we were in a whole
different situation
and that's when i started calling for
shelter in place
and you accurately portrayed that
unfortunately i had to fight with our
state's governor but that's what we
needed to do the moment it was clear to
me we needed to have shelter in place if
we had implemented that right then if
new york city had had that power that
would have been the difference maker
and i only wish we had had a very
different situation than that would have
allowed me to do that
a lot of people at the time said the
rivalry between you and then governor
andrew cuomo cost new yorkers lives do
you accept that even if you put the
blame on him not yourself but do you
accept the politics of that time
definitely did cost rise you know i
don't think it's productive uh to
relitigate i think what's clear is and i
want to be fair even to andrew cuomo you
can imagine that's a tough statement for
me to say
in the end it is a global pandemic
we had no national leadership we did not
have testing we had misinformation
coming out of the white house we were
dealing with the great unknown even our
best scientists and healthcare leaders
here in new york city only had very
initial knowledge about the disease we
have to put all that in perspective
we can do a lot of monday morning
quarterback but i think what's clear now
what's clear now is
that once it became clear the details
and the facts we had to be very
aggressive
and here and around the country the
answer was to do things like shelter in
place we finally got there
but
now we have a situation that's so much
clearer and that's what's shocking that
around the country there isn't a
devotion to vaccination we're a hundred
percent devoted to it and that's why new
york city actually is coming back and
living the life we're living right now
undeniably true
let me ask you about andrew cuomo though
former governor
did you know had you heard rumors about
andrew cuomo and his alleged misconduct
around women because a lot of people in
new york say this was known and it was
kind of just people turned a blind eye
well i was focused on
his misconduct when it came to nursing
homes
which was profoundly damaging
uh obviously we saw there was misconduct
literally around the distribution
of testing and vaccinations and
political favoritism there that i was
honestly focused on the context of covid
and the damage that was being done
when we started to hear the individual
stories they were terrifying that these
women had been put through this
and i give all the credit in the world
to the women who came forward taking an
immense risk
because they finally shocked a lot of
people in the state who had looked the
other way on andrew cuomo into realizing
exactly who he was
and i understand where your focus was
but i've been asked again because you
didn't quite answer the question you
were unaware of any of those women's
stories before they came forward you had
no idea
of the specific stories no of course not
anyone who was should have come forward
with them i didn't know about those but
i was deeply concerned about a host of
other problems and they've all they're
all true this is the this is the reality
maddie all these things
all these mistakes all these sins all
these horrible actions
uh happen simultaneously and they're
only now just beginning to be unpacked
and i'll tell you the investigators and
the prosecutors have a lot to work with
and you can expect a lot more chapters
in this story
you've said that andrew cuomo is a
tyrant you've said that he should be
criminally charged do you believe that
he will be some some might say americans
tend not to put such powerful people
behind bars
i think there's a mixed bag in that area
but in new york state we've certainly
seen a lot of powerful people go to jail
who richly deserve to
there's a number of places where he may
be prosecuted so i don't rule it out at
all
one last question mr mayor the next
mayor of new york if it's a democrat
will be eric adams former police officer
former republican you've endorsed him he
and many around him say his victory in
the primaries was a victory for
moderates and a rejection of woke
progressives how does that make you feel
as a self-professed progressive mayor
was his win a defeat for the left of
your party which you have long
identified with
yeah i don't accept the analysis eric
adams
was a profound activist
fighting against improper police
practices from within the police
department
doing extraordinary work on civil rights
decades ago
he is a working class guy from brooklyn
who represents the interests of working
people
i've worked with him very closely a lot
of the most progressive initiatives of
this administration i i don't accept
that simplification i think you're going
to see a continuity
with a lot of the progressive policies
that we created over the last eight
years
i hope you're right although some of
that analysis comes from him and people
around him not from me but mayor bill de
blasio i appreciate you taking time out
and taking my questions thank you
thank you